[Music]
the magnificence of the Amazon
rainforest is difficult to describe from
the air it is quite an extraordinary
sight its impenetrable canopy of trees
broken only by the Amazon River and its
hundreds of huge tributaries and streams
30% of the world's species live in the
vast Amazon basin more species of birds
plants and mammals inhabit this forest
than anywhere else on earth
400 billion trees store 86 billion tons
of carbon without the Amazon rainforest
the world's climates would be thrown out
of kilter it literally helps the world
to breathe 20% of the world's entire
oxygen supply is produced here without
it
experts say global warming it is huge
yes but it's getting smaller logging and
farming the biggest source of danger
it seems impenetrable in small squares
of green appear this is the loggers of
work secretly cutting down trees deep in
the forest
then more green begins to appear
and then more and suddenly the forest
just disappears replaced with mile after
mile a farmer
it looks like rural England the point is
it just shouldn't this is the town of
Nova Progresso or new progress it's in
the hunt of the rainforest and it's a
big place now it's home to ranchers and
miners
it's a boomtown and under bolson ro the
good times are about to get better
this is home to super high end farming
the ranches are spectacular because it's
been a rain forest for millions of years
it's incredibly nutritious the economics
are remarkable in Texas for example 15
acres of land can support one cow here
15 acres can support 30 cows a gammon on
the silver Menezes his head of the
farmers you were he once famously
quipped nobody misses dinosaurs why
would they miss trees we joined him at
this ranch that is specializing in
genetically modified Bulls it is quite a
remarkable sight
the biggest bull I've ever seen
they bulk heard any criticism they deny
climate change and like the president
pour scorn on countries who challenged
kikyo whoops face officer Moira taratata
is about altitude plant an initiative
that was seeking support for us in over
supportin at amicable a solicitation
same thing with other key to the first
intelligent reasons to pull cases - beer
- a key to the desert
[Applause]
70% of deforestation in Brazil is caused
by ranching and this is what it looks
like when it starts mud roads have
bulldoze through the forest to allow the
logging trucks to get in slowly but
surely the trees are pushed aside by the
bulldozers there's no law out here the
loggers are notoriously unfriendly and
dangerous outsiders aren't welcome more
environmental journalists and activists
are killed here than anywhere else
trees are left on the side of the road
waiting to be taken away by the trucks
this is illegal but it's hugely
lucrative so this area was deforested
about a year ago we're told give some
idea of how much money this is worth
when this has cut down and they will
come back for this and sold it goes to
about two hundred and fifty dollars when
it gets to the marketplace the
international marketplace these
beautiful trees will go for about three
thousand dollars this is a very badly
hit part of the Amazon last year over
100,000 football fields of trees were
cut down
after years of well organized government
control protection the loggers are back
and cutting through the forest at record
levels we don't really think of trees
being endangered in the same way as we
do animals but for conservationists
these areas of dying trees burnt to make
them easier to cut down it's as
heartbreaking as an elephant or rhino
being killed this is put simply a tree
graveyard Thiago Alves is a forestry
worker despite all their efforts the
situation he says has become impossible
the loggers are winning material
Tigrinya a flora status into the bastard
he problema being taught that otherwise
my own
[Music]
the tributaries of the Amazon are huge
rivers in their own right
this is the Jingu river it's well over a
thousand miles long and runs through the
state of Para north to the Amazon
Paris State for some of the most
environmentally damaged areas in the
Amazon
the forest and its rivers are
intrinsically linked
but both are being damaged in different
ways
sections of the forest are drowning from
a huge rise in water levels caused by a
hydroelectric dam upstream
it affects the trees the animals the
fish the river and vitally it affects
the people who live here
the indigenous
twenty-five thousand of them from 18
distinct ethnic groups live along the
Jamuna
they're calling out there but we've been
prepping and traveling into the
rainforest for most of the day now we're
hoping to meet with the indigenous
population is live here there are many
orphans of course in different groups
around the whole of the Amazon but they
are saying they need outside help
because they're being threatened by
loggers who have come onto their land
and it's simply refusing to leave we're
coming to see what it is they're so
worried about
we traveled north through treacherous
rocky sections of the river and through
Rapids only locals can navigate finally
we reach the home of the Azeri me people
there are only about two or three
hundred of them living in and off the
forest and the river
first official contact of the azzurrini
was in 1971 and it was made by this man
Marrero was chosen to walk out of the
forest to contact the white man he has
no idea how long it took but it was
almost certainly months possibly years
he was sent to find help because he has
araignee
risked being wiped out by tribal
fighting nearly 50 years later
threatened by land invasions from
loggers and illegal miners they're
calling out for help once again what
theater the land is everything in our
life Moreira told me without the land we
cannot live dear the azzurrini
are hunter-gatherers fruits and
vegetables from the rainforest fish from
the river and wild animals
[Music]
join them on a hunt
[Music]
they have to travel much further these
days by boat because the animals have
been scared off by the water
hunting in the forest is very difficult
the dogs try to push their prey towards
the river forcing them to swim to safety
the hunting team then get back on board
and search for their quarry it's a deer
the chase is on there is only one engine
and it's pretty brutal
[Music]
Fairley who renders to wash up it was
called this dear test out swimming and
they saw it suddenly the boat started
rushing fool and they've got it now the
dogs get back in though we've heard
we've caught one
there is no sport in this the entire
village benefits from the hunt the
forest the river the animals and the
humans live here in harmony when the
lands are invaded everything changes the
indigenous people live off the forest
they hunted in they gather vegetables
and fruit
but they move on the river so what's
really vital to them is that the river
is healthy to let the forest as healthy
and then they can live if either is
damaged their whole lifestyle just goes
wrong the Azeri knees second in charge
told me that his people are being
threatened by armed illegal loggers he
fears other indigenous groups may have
been murdered for their land
hello his pathetic person who - no -
look gardening food for I'm with my
little fish in 20 series magnificant OB
doesn't he so so vindicated amazon aqui
he oversaw international policy Cory
he'll meet you Amazon
the world needs the Amazon but right now
the Amazon needs the world just as much
the Brazilian government argues it has a
right to farm and to explore its own
natural resources clearly that is true
but for two decades Brazil accepted its
responsibility as the custodian of this
wonder of the world this country
arguably needs help to change its ways
if that is what the world wants if not
the forest the river and its people may
be lost forever
you